Mexico is in fashion in Hollywood.
While Donald Trump
keeps trying to build the wall at the southern
border,
Mexican movie directors have won 5 of the
past 6 Oscars
for best director.
But, as talented as Mexicans are in the film
industry, they are far less lucky when it
comes to politics.
A
year ago, we told you how the country of Guillermo
del Toro
ended years of bipartisan politics that lead
to rampant
corruption.
For a better understanding, the country’s
latest
president, Enrique Peña Nieto, left office
with the worst
ratings any Mexican president has ever had.
And this is how the new president began his
term.
Of
course, we’re talking about ANDRES MANUEL
LOPEZ
OBRADOR, also known as AMLO, the new Mexican
left-
wing rockstar.
He is the first president to win more than
million votes.
That’s a landslide victory.
And it’s even more
surprising if we take into account that he
didn’t come from
either of the two major political parties.
Mexicans wanted a
radical change and that’s exactly what AMLO
promised.
The question now is… is he delivering?
And Xander is going to give us the answer.
And Erik is going to give us the answer.
Truth be told… yes, things are changing
in Mexico.
They
are changing for the worse.
Their GDP growth rate was 2%
in 2018, but in 2019, they’re only projected
to grow about
0.2%.
Yes, so far it seems like Mexico is heading
towards a
recession.
And yes, yes, I know what you’re thinking…
Come on,
Simon!
The brand new Mexican president hasn’t even
been
in office for a year.
Can we really blame him for what’s
going on in the country?
Today, we are going to answer to
this question.
But before we do, let’s take a look back
at the
history.
THE REVENANT
Yes, I’m sure many of you have watched that
movie.
‘The
Revenant’s Mexican director, Alejandro González
Iñarritu,
won his second Oscar for best director with
this film.
But the
real revenant in this story is AMLO.
He started his career as
a member of one of those two big Mexican political
parties:
The Institutional Revolutionary Party, also
known as PRI.
This used to be the country’s big center-left
party.
But
AMLO soon realized that this party wasn’t
far enough to the
left for him.
So he created his own spin-off that led him
to
become the Mayor of Mexico City.
This is how AMLO became famous nation-wide.
Then, in
2006, he ran for President but lost by 250,000
votes.
Instead of accepting the result, AMLO started
several
protests and his supporters claimed he was
the legitimate
president.
Then he ran for president again in 2012, with
even worse results.
At the time, it seemed like his career
was over.
Yes, nobody would invest a penny in AMLO´s
future.
But
then, against the odds, he rose from his ashes
with a brand
new political party: MORENA.
His program was very simple:
destroy everything the previous administrations
had done in
Mexico and start from scratch.
And oh boy!
In a country as
corrupt politically dysfunctional, and poverty-stricken
as
Mexico, this formula couldn’t have worked
better.
And let’s be honest here…
AMLO isn’t disappointing
anyone.
You see, in Mexico, after winning the elections,
you have to
wait 5 months before you really start being
the president.
During this time, the would-be president just
waits.
But
AMLO used this 5 months to hold lots of referendums.
His
idea was that, as soon as he started his term,
he would
already have a list of popular policies ready
to be
implemented.
And now you might say, Oh!
That doesn’t seem like a bad
idea, right?
You guys at VisualPolitik have already praised
direct democracy in countries like Liechtenstein
and
Switzerland!
So you must be big AMLO fans!
Yes, you’re right, referendums can be pretty
cool.
But they
must have guarantees and be organized by the
government.
When a political party organizes referendums
by themselves without any controls, it’s
usually a joke.
And
this is exactly what AMLO has been doing.
For most of these referendums, only 1 out
of 5
municipalities actually had voting cabins.
And the elections were so rigged that… that…
well… just
look at this news!
A person could vote 4 times on the referendum
about the
new airport
But this is not the end of the story!
You see, when we talk
about referendums, the way we write the question
can have
a big impact on the outcome.
In other words, if you change
the wording, you can easily manipulate the
result.
For
example, if I ask…
“Do you agree with increasing old
people’s pensions?”
Or “Do you want a better healthcare
system?”
I’m sure most of you would say YES.
Well… these
were the kinds of questions people from the
MORENA party
asked.
And how many citizens voted?
Most of the
referendums had a turnout lower than 1%---about
equal to
the percentage of absolute die-hard AMLO supporters.
And,
of course, all these policies had more than
90% approval
ratings.
Of course, none of these referendums had any
legal
backing.
But they have been the perfect way for AMLO
to
justify all his decisions.
At the end of the day, Hey!
He’s just
doing what the citizens want!
And now you might wonder… what kind of decisions
is
AMLO making?
Here’s an example!
Cancelling the
construction of Mexico City&#39;s New International
Airport.
We
don’t know if the Project was good or bad.
But the truth is it
costs 13 billion dollars of which 5 billion
were already spent.
So basically, Mexico has just thrown 5 billion
USD out the
window.
And you might wonder…
Why did he do that?
Easy!
One of those referendums, where only 1% of
the
population voted, said that the public agreed
with cancelling
construction.
In a way, you can argue that many other politicians
base
their policies on polls.
But the difference is that AMLO sees
this as a real legal instrument.
We are going to govern like this: asking the
people.
They
say that, in order to avoid mistakes, the
best policy is to
ask.
This is democracy!
It’s not the decision of one man, or
two, or three!...
Again, the problem is not making referendums.
In fact,
Mexican law already has legislation in place
to regulate how
to make popular consultations.
But, of course, you need an
independent body to run the process and you
need to reach
a certain turnout.
Until this year, 2019, this turnout was 40%
of voters.
But, of course, AMLO has already changed this.
Now 25% is enough.
25% of Mexican voters is around 20
million people.
But there are consultations in which less
than 1 million people voted.
In other words, for AMLO, direct democracy
is pretty
undemocratic.
But wait a minute because we aren’t done
yet!
Apart from consultations... what has AMLO
done in the
few months he’s been in power?
Well... he’s been pretty
busy.
Let’s check it out, shall we?
AMLO WORLD
AMLO’s presidency can be summarized in one
iconic
gesture.
Unlike his predecessors, he didn’t want
to live in
the LOS PINOS palace.
You might say, “Oh!
That’s great!
A
man of the people, just like JOSE MUJICA in
Uruguay!”
But
the question is... where do you think he went
instead?
Did
he remain at home?
Of course he didn’t!
He went to the
national palace!
In other words: he just switched one palace
for the other.
And what do you think he did with the LOS
PINOS palace?
The place has now become a cultural center.
The first big
event was a public screening of ROMA, the
movie directed
by ALFONSO CUARON, in order to promote Mexican
movies.
And, in this regard, we must admit he was
very
transparent.
The ministry of Culture will have to report
how much they
spent in popcorn and punch during the projection
of ROMA
in LOS PINOS
OK, OK, but let’s be clear here... projecting
ROMA in the
LOS PINOS palace is not a bad thing.
It’s not a good thing
either.
But what actually has negative consequences
for the
economy and does scare investors away are
decisions like
cancelling the construction of the airport
and changing all
the deals the previous government had signed
with private
contractors.
And this explains news like this.
Mexico falls eight positions in the foreign
direct investment
ranking.
Also Mexico fell to the last position in the
ranking
prepared by A.T.
Kearney.
And the same goes for the energy reform.
You see, after
decades of having a state monopoly, the Mexican
oil
company, PEMEX, couldn’t be more corrupt.
They had an
enormous amount of debt and, if it wasn’t
for the
Government’s support, they would have gone
bankrupt
years ago.
The previous president, Peña Nieto, opened
the market for
foreign investment.
He started by auctioning the smallest oil
fields off to anybody who wanted to exploit
them.
The goal
was to increase production and generate more
money.
The first thing AMLO did as soon as he got
into office was
freeze all those public auctions.
He wants Mexico’s oil
industry to remain the way it was.
And this is a problem
because the country has a big management issue
in this
regard.
For example, even though Mexico has oil reserves,
it imports 70% of its gasoline from the United
States, which
leads to higher gasoline prices.
Why does it import so
much?
Mainly because PEMEX is so mismanaged that
their
production falls every year.
And how is AMLO trying to solve this?
Of course, by
building a brand new refinery!
The problem?
PEMEX has
no money and Mexico isn’t growing anymore
so... where is
he going to get the money?
That’s a very good question!
Mexican Government and Pemex announcement
of building
a new refinery raises many doubts.
So far, all the contractors that have been
participating in the
bidding claimed that the conditions the government
requested were not realistic.
They want the refinery too
early and for too little money.
But I guess we will have to
wait until 2022 to see who’s right.
But we can already judge the success of the
education
reform.
This is another project started by the previous
president that was stopped by AMLO.
In this case, Mexico
had a unique educational system.
In most countries,
teachers have to pass an exam in order to
be hired by a
public school.
Not here!
In this case, it’s the Teacher’s
union that controls the hiring process.
And a teaching
position can be SOLD or even INHERITED.
Yes, you heard
that right.
You can inherit a teacher’s job from your
father!
And you don’t even need to prove that you
know the
subjects you’re going to teach!
This is why Mexico changed the system and
introduced a
national exam.
It’s a similar system to Spain’s, for
example.
But in Mexico, the change sparked extremely
violent
protests, especially in the South of the country.
Thousands of teachers retired before having
to pass this
exam.
And more than a thousand teachers were fired
because, after three attempts, they couldn’t
pass.
Most of
them, of course, got another job at the administration.
But don’t worry!
This is all history!
One of the most vocal
AMLO supporters during the campaign were those
teachers’ unions.
So now he’s returning the favour by going
backwards on those reforms.
So Mexican teachers will once
again enjoy their privileges.
And Mexican kids will keep
failing all the exams on the PISA report.
But, by far, the most controversial thing
AMLO has done
involves his war against the narcos.
When Mexico was
governed by the right wing, it passed a law
to allow the
military to fight the narcos.
This definitely didn’t work.
In the
last 12 years, Mexico had more than 250,000
deaths
directly linked to the war on drugs.
AMLO promised he
would stop this war.
So... what did he do?
Well, instead of using the military...
he’s created a brand new body called the
NATIONAL
GUARD.
And who’s part of this national guard?
Of course!
Former soldiers!
Even the leader is a former military officer.
So basically, AMLO changed everything... to
keep
everything the same.
And the same is happening with lots of social
programs and
even the Mexico City airport.
Yes, we talked about that
before.
You might think he did that to save money,
right?
Well... not really!
That money is being reinvested in another
project with a more dubious utility: the MAYAN
TRAIN.
This
train will cross the Southern Mexican states.
Which would
be great if those regions were more developed.
So, with no
people or goods to transport, it’s wishful
thinking to believe
that this is going to push development in
the region.
But this
isn’t even the worse thing!
Mayan organizations ask AMLO to stop the construction
of
the Mayan Train
So far, the project hasn’t passed any of
the environmental
impact studies.
But, still, AMLO’s administration keeps
trying.
In this political climate, where the president
isn’t listening to
anybody, it’s easy to understand why foreign
investors are
leaving the country by the dozens.
And this has already had
an impact on the country’s economic growth.
So now the
question goes to you.
Do you think AMLO will manage to avoid a recession
in
Mexico?
Or do you think the money that’s running
away
from the country will never come back?
Please, leave your
answer in the comment section below.
Also, don’t forget to visit RECONSIDER MEDIA.COM,
the
PODCAST that provided the vocals on this episode
that
were not mine.
Don’t forget that we publish brand new
videos every week so subscribe to VisualPolitik
and hit that
bell button so you won’t miss any posts.
If you liked this
video, give us a thumbs up and, as always,
I’ll see you next
time.